Wow, I love your new car!
Yeah, it's really fast.
Driving down to the tent?
Soon as we've started the show.
BOTH: Welcome to
The Great British Bake Off.
See you, Paul!
ENGINE PURRS
Do you want a lift?
Uh, I, I think I'll walk.
Wow, such an athlete.
Got to get my steps in.
BIRDSONG
Getting to the semifinal meant
surviving the trials of pastry week.
No-one wants a soggy tart.
And it was Steph...
It's delicious.
..who emerged victorious again...
Just got Star
Baker for the fourth time.
..while Rosie's performance
put her in the bottom two...
Your filling is very dry.
It's very bitty.
..in the end...
Quack!
..it was another baker...
It just doesn't look good.
..who proved to be...
Hot damn!
..extra flaky...
Henry.
..and their time in the tent was up.
It's been a pleasure, darling.
This time...
Ooh, way too hot!
..the bakers tackle high-end
patisserie...
This is not good.
..and geometry...
Roll the pastry into a square.
..with a domed signature...
Yes!
..a symmetrical technical...
Cut into two rectangles.
I can kind of picture what
it looks like.
..and a sugar cube showstopper.
If you break it, gone.
Excellence is expected...
It's the semifinal,
it's the semifinal.
..and the smallest of slip-ups...
I need to chill out
because I'm getting stressed.
..could dash their dreams...
I never feel calm.
..of competing in the final.
I'm having a total disaster.
They've definitely picked
a difficult one
but then, you wouldn't
expect any less.
BIRDSONG
It's the semifinal and
the four remaining bakers
must be cut down to a last lucky
three for next week's Grand Final.
So special to be in the semifinals,
regardless of what happens
this week.
Yes, the semifinal!
What?!
It's not the week to drop the ball.
I definitely would like to go
through to the final.
I would be buzzing for that.
No-one gets to the semifinal
and goes,
"Don't really want to
do the final. Nah."
If they are to triumph,
the bakers must succeed
in three intense
and demanding patisserie challenges.
I do not know
a lot about patisserie.
Fancy pies and tarts? I've just
never been interested in doing them.
This week's is blooming difficult
because everything's so fiddly.
I think patisserie's gonna test
everything I've learnt so far.
It needs to be kind of refined and
it needs to kind of look perfect.
I'm a bit worried about that.
Technically this is
one of the hardest things we'll do.
Morning bakers,
welcome back to the tent
and your very first
semifinal challenge.
Today the judges would like you to
make something that Sandi is
very passionate about.
Yeah, honestly. These are like
the creme de la creme
of the bakery world. Yeah, no, these
are domed tartlets, right?
What's not to get excit...?
SHE HYPERVENTILATES
It, uh, it's... You'll have to take
over. It's too much for me. OK!
The judges would like you
to make eight...
Eight!
SANDI CHUCKLES
..elegant, beautifully
decorated, domed tartlets.
They must have a sweet pastry case
and be exquisitely decorated.
You've got two and a half hours.
On your marks...
..Get set...
..bake!
I'm feeling quite nervous.
It definitely hasn't sunk in that
I'm in the semifinal. That's crazy.
I think in a couple of months' time
I'll be like, whoa!
The Signature Challenge this
week is a domed tart.
It's very much a French pastry,
this,
so we expect that little
bit of... je ne sais quoi.
They need to be absolutely
identical.
They need to be as neat as pins.
This challenge is all about timing,
it's about precision
and it's about the setting.
We want that flakiness
and butteriness
that a good sweet pastry brings
and then you want to pack a punch
with the top.
It's definitely the hardest week
they've done so far
but it's the semifinal
and we have to find the three best
bakers to go through to the final.
SQUEEZY BOTTLE PARPS
Pardon you!
DRAWN-OUT, BUBBLING PARP
Wearing a tie for young Henry,
who we miss intensely.
Henry left.
He's living on in us this week
but it's quite hot in the tent
so I think I'm gonna take it off.
What's the key
to getting this bake right?
The riskiest thing is
just everything setting
and getting it done in time.
I'm gonna make my pastry
cases which is a chocolate, sweet
shortcrust pastry.
And it's really delicate.
Well, that's the aim anyway.
Morning.
Alice. Hello, Alice.
Happy semifinal!
Thank you! Yeah.
Tell us all about your domed tart.
Uh, so I am doing a mocha orange
and hazelnut domed tart.
Well, I think you've won.
I think that's it.
Alice's domes will be filled with
a mocha mousse,
an orange curd
and a hazelnut praline paste
and topped off with
a chocolate mirror glaze.
How big are these tartlets gonna
be?
They're quite, uh,
they're quite big.
Oh, wow, OK. That's quite a lot
of very rich stuff.
You just get more, you know,
yumminess that way.
I love the idea of chocolate
and hazelnut together.
It's one of my favourite things.
Good luck.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
I'm making a...
I can't say it. Pa... pate sablee?
Something like that.
It's quite a rich pastry.
It's almost like shortbread.
Sounds French.
Steph's domes will be covered in a
white chocolate glaze filled with
a raspberry jelly and lemon mousse
perched on a pate sablee pastry.
Do you not think "Pat Sablee"
sounds like a singer?
"Welcome to the stage, Pat Sablee!"
"Coming in at number two!" Yeah!
THEY LAUGH
I mean, obviously
we're at semifinal stage.
Well, you've won the most
Star Bakers this year.
I know.
Do you see yourself in the final?
I'm trying to just take each bake as
it comes and what will be will be.
Good luck, Steph.
Thank you. Good luck, Steph.
I'm just lining my pastry cases.
I don't want any gaps
or any leaky filling.
This is pate sablee pastry.
Things that come into your head
when you think "patisserie" is just
super neat, super precise. Yes,
she says, cobbling together random
bits of pastry, but, whatever.
If you get through - final!
Did you think you were good?
Well, my family think I'm good.
Family always think you're good.
When I used to do stand-up gigs and
I'd absolutely die on my arse
my mum and dad would go,
"We thought you were funny."
I think you're funny!
I laugh at you all the time.
That's what my mum says!
"I think you're funny."
I'm doing hazelnut
biscuit at the bottom.
I didn't want to do a whole case.
That'll just go straight in the oven
and then I cut the circles
afterwards.
So they are going in for
12-14 minutes at 175.
With their bases in the oven,
the bakers can start on the first
of their domes' multiple fillings.
Right, what's next? Zest a lemon.
This is the filling for my dome.
It kind of, it all revolves
around the drink, a liqueur spritz.
I think it's delicious.
David's aperitif jelly will be
encased in a leche flan dome
perched on an orange pastry disc
topped with a mirror glaze
flavoured with more
of the botanical Italian spirit.
How do you feel about the
possibility of being in the final?
It's quite scary, actually.
And we're gonna keep coming round
and reminding you of that though.
"It's the semifinal,
it's the semifinal!"
Good luck, David. Thanks.
SHE HUFFS
David's not the only baker
opting for an alcoholic flavour.
My tarts are lemon, raspberry
and mint with a hint of gin
with some pulled sugar strands
and some silver leaf.
I was gonna have another
element in there
and I cut it out cos I'm, I'm being,
I'm being sensible.
Yeah, I know. I don't think I'm
gonna get it done, am I?
But... you know.
Rosie's pate sablee pastry case
will have a raspberry gin and
mint creme pat,
a lemon Bavarian cream dome,
finished with a lemon mirror glaze.
I can't believe you made this far.
Oh, thanks(!) Cheers.
Joking, joking.
Semifinal's pretty good.
Semifinal is good enough.
Yeah, but you want to go,
"I got to the final," don't you,
cos you're a vet.
If you only get to the semifinal,
you'll be operating on like a pony
or something that'll come to
and go, "semifinal? Jesus, not
even the final!" I know!
I don't think I like you any more!
I'm joking. Meanie! You've done
amazingly well.
This is the lemon mousse.
I hope it's gonna be really lemony.
They never tell you that you need
biceps of steel in this competition.
Oh, yeah, my arms are aching.
This is my chocolate mocha mousse.
I need the mousse to freeze.
These need to
be in the freezer ASAP.
You need to turn them out
when they're absolutely frozen.
The bakers are using moulds to
achieve the all-important dome.
But if their soft, sloppy fillings
are to take shape
it's vital they freeze solid.
Hopefully they'll pop out nicely.
Blooming 'eck. Let's hope so, eh?
I mean, it's the domed tart so
I need, I need these domes to work.
Go straight into the freezer.
So we're going in for as long
as possible.
And get in the freezer and hopefully
set as quick as they can.
BIRDSONG
Right we got to do a time call.
Has anyone seen Sandi?
Oh, there she is.
OK. Bakers, you are halfway through!
Halfway through.
Don't worry, I got this.
Right I think I'll get
the tarts out.
That is ready now actually, yeah.
That's what I want.
Just go with that.
Got to cut my circles out now
while it's still warm.
I'm happy with the colour.
The tops are a bit scrappy.
I don't really know why the tops are
scrappy but in the grand scheme of
things if the pastry's cooked,
who really cares? Pfft, you know.
They've spread a bit
but it is what it is.
Yeah, that's done, phew.
To sandwich their tart cases
and domes
the bakers are creating something
that packs in more flavour...
Right,
next I'm gonna do my liqueur jelly.
..but they must
get the balance right
or risk overpowering
the rest of the bake.
This is my yuzu jelly.
Yuzu is citrus but it's really,
really, really strong.
That's why
it's only very, very small jelly.
This is for my raspberry jelly.
I do love a bit of fruit in pretty
much everything I do.
This is my orange curd.
I want it fairly thick cos it's got
to support the dome.
Have you ever fixed a gorilla? No.
A chimp?
No, no, monkeys just no monkeys.
No primates? I'm sorry.
Just sort of farm animals?
Yeah, I've treated pigs,
castrated many pigs.
Castra... wow!
Wow!
Castrated pigs!
What's the biggest animal
you've castrated?
A giant bull.
A bull?
Bulls are quite angry anyway.
I bet when he woke up he was fuming.
Right, double cream,
double cream, double cream.
The bakers' domes will be built
up of seven separate elements,
each one giving them a chance to
showcase their flair for flavour.
I'm just making the espresso
buttercream.
Rhubarb!
So these'll be roasted in the oven.
One of my favourite flavours.
I just don't like things too sweet.
I'm doing the creme pat raspberry
mix. I hate eating it.
I think it's horrible.
I hate anything that's custardy
but it is useful
as a base for things.
Getting there. It's the last half
an hour that really stresses me out.
It's like, "Yeah, everything's
fine," and then it's like,
"Oh, God! What if NOT
everything is fine?"
You all right, Noel?
You look a bit tired.
I'm fine, I'm fine. OK.
Bakers, you got half an hour left,
half an hour.
Oh, dear!
Oh!
I never feel calm.
I think even
when I'm done I don't feel calm.
I do sometimes flap.
Right, mirror glaze.
To hide any kind of dodgy
bits of mirror glaze.
It's a white chocolate mirror glaze.
Bit of sweetness in there, cos
it's quite tart, the rest of it.
This is white
chocolate for my mirror glaze.
I want this to be about 32.
Ooooh! Way too hot.
Just a little bit too hot, still.
I'm just gonna leave it completely
alone for two minutes then it's
just gonna have to go cos I haven't
got any time to do anything else.
The rhubarb you
want to be JUST cooked.
It looks good. So, construct.
I need to assemble it all.
My creme pate's too thin.
Eejit, eejit, eejit.
This is hazelnut praline paste.
It's not spreading.
Come on, you.
Oh, this is so annoying.
I'm just gonna use my fingers.
Don't judge.
The one thing that's a shame is
that you don't see the rhubarb.
One time I did make a larger base
so you could still see it.
But then it just didn't
really look very good.
This is for my chocolate drizzle.
How long have I got to go?
Bakers, you have ten minutes left,
just ten minutes for your domed
tartlets.
Yes! Domed tartlets!
OK!
I need to get my domes out
and hope that they are... frozen.
If the bakers'
domes aren't set solid
they'll be impossible to get
out of the mould without damaging.
OK. Come on. Looks like they're OK.
Pure mocha mousse.
That's where the jelly's gonna go.
I'm really scared.
A lot softer than it was at home.
I feel like this is all
gonna go wrong.
Like so.
They're like little
sort of sweet Scotch eggs.
Yeah. But with no egg.
In my mind, domed tartlets
were like, you know, Center Parcs.
I like little domes.
Scotch eggs. They look good!
They're fine.
They look like very small implants.
Massively freaking out.
It's definitely way more
set at home.
To coat the domes properly
and create the desired shine
the mirror glaze must be
the perfect consistency.
Yes, too thin really. But, yeah,
I'll use up all the glaze I've got.
They'll still be shiny - they'll
just be a bit rubbish looking.
I'm not happy with it in general.
It's all a bit of a mess.
Bakers, you have five minutes. Oh!
On you go.
Yes!
This is supposed to be beautifully
set before, you know, whatever.
There you go.
Just piping my buttercream.
I need to chill out
because I'm getting stressed.
My hands are getting clammy.
I literally can't grip
this blimmin' piping bag.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Just one minute.
To get my layer of crunch on.
Bakers, your time is up!
Done.
Please place your domed tartlets
at the end of your work stations.
David, please place one of those
drinks in my hand.
I'll have the bottle.
My creme pat isn't set.
It's sort of oozing out the top
and when they cut it that one is
gonna splodge out
so they're not gonna like that.
I've got some domed tarts at least.
They look like boobs.
Never mind!
SANDI: The bakers' domed tarts
will now face the judgment
of Paul and Prue.
Hello, David. Hiya.
I love them. They look so unusual.
I've never seen anything
like that in a pastry shop
and I would want to buy one.
Colour's nice, it's all uniform.
If you're going to put nuts
around the outside
blitz them down even smaller.
The smaller they are, the more
professional it'll look.
I love the flavour.
The bitterness that comes through
is from the aperitif,
which you've got in the jelly form.
It's delicious.
I don't think it looks particularly
good, but I do like the flavours.
Particularly the rhubarb.
Hmm.
Because the rhubarb cuts through
the general richness of it all.
Can I have a slug of that?
That's for you!
The excuse is it's a good palate
clearer for the next one.
True. Thanks you very much, David.
Thanks, David.
Thanks, guys.
Thank you.
WHISPERING: OK, see you later.
I absolutely love the colour.
I think the size of them is perfect.
The base... don't look too bad.
Nice little bits of pulled sugar,
I like that.
It's a shame about the creme pat.
It needs cooking out
that little bit more.
It's just a little bit too soft.
The jelly is perfect.
It's a shame about the creme pat.
It's not very neat down
at the bottom... Yeah.
..on any one of them.
I like the design, I love that.
And the colours.
It's akin to a lemon meringue pie.
OK.
The sharpness is there, the flavours
are there, but it's a bit too soft.
I agree it's a bit soft...
Yeah, it is. ..but if you were
eating it as a pudding, with a
spoon, you'd be fine. Yeah.
Nearly perfect.
Thanks, thank you.
The dome - the shine you've achieved
on that is fantastic.
The pipework is not
particularly good.
It's such a pity, Alice, because,
I mean, that one is near perfect
and some of the others are
really all over the place. Yeah.
But the overall look is
pretty professional.
Oh, my goodness.
It's held together quite nicely.
The pastry's lovely and crisp,
nice flavour.
You've got a lovely buttery feel
to it cos it crumbles in your mouth
and it melts beautifully.
The orange comes through.
It's quite a big tartlet...
Yeah.
..but they are really good.
The only thing that let you down
was the piping. Yeah.
But I think your flavours and your
textures and actual base
are stunning. I think your flavours
are gorgeous, well done.
Thank you very much.
I am SO happy with that.
I will take that. I'll take
my rubbish piping any day.
They liked the flavours and
that's the most important thing.
They're judging quite harshly today.
It seems like they're picking people
up on lots of little issues.
Their only negative was that
my creme pat wasn't set.
And I did know that.
I knew that mousse hadn't set
properly. I have no idea why.
I feel like the Technical
might really matter this week
with only four of us.
The Technical for patisserie is
quite terrifying, I think.
Yeah, patisserie Technical, that's
not going to be easy, is it?
SANDI: As usual, the bakers may have
practised their signature bakes,
but, when it comes to the Technical,
what they will be making
is a complete mystery.
Hello, lovelies, it's time for your
Technical Challenge,
which today has been set for you by
the lovely Prue.
Prue, any words of wisdom?
This is very difficult to make look
good.
Oh, God.
Good luck.
NOEL LAUGHS
OK.
As ever, this Technical Challenge
will be judged blind
so we're going to have to ask these
two cuties to leave the tent.
Bye. Off you pop.
Where are they going?
I believe Prue is respraying
Paul's tan. OK.
Prue would like you to make
gateau St Honore,
named after...
Obviously Saint Honore, you knew
that, right? Yeah? Absolutely.
The French patron saint of
bakers and pastry chefs.
He was like a kind of Prue Leith of
his day,
but without the challenging
necklaces. Wow.
Hmm, yeah, so unlike
the classic round gateau shape
you may be familiar with, Prue
would like your gateau St Honore
to be rectangular and
comprised of two layers.
The first layer must be puff pastry,
followed by choux buns dipped in
sweet caramel and then filled
with a silky creme chiboust.
You've no idea what you just said,
have you? No.
Repeat that for the second layer and
finish with piped Chantilly cream.
You have three and a half hours.
On your marks. Get set. Bake!
Oh, there's a lot of writing here.
I feel like I have heard of it
and I can kind of picture what
it looks like.
I'm just going to try and not
stress.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I've made this a long time ago and
it went wrong.
And I never made it again.
They've definitely picked
a difficult one,
but then we wouldn't expect
any less.
This looks pretty complicated.
SHE LAUGHS
This is the Semifinal!
It's not meant to be easy.
It's a gateau St Honore.
It's really difficult to
make it not look a mess.
EVERYTHING has to be right.
The choux buns have to be
the right size,
the creams have to be
the right texture,
the pastry has to be thin
and neatly trimmed.
They have to do puff pastry, which
is going to be quite difficult.
I think it's a great challenge.
It's one of the most wonderful
French patisseries.
I mean, that looks beautiful.
Nice crisp caramel.
Mmm! The choux pastry is filled with
really satiny creme chiboust,
which is basically creme patissiere
but with some egg whites
to lighten it.
It's crispy puff,
nicely set choux buns,
and you've got that softness
coming from the chiboust
and from the Chantilly.
The combination is fantastic.
Diabetes on a plate.
SHE LAUGHS
This is worth every
single calorie, Paul.
Right, I'm just going to
get on with it.
Er, we're making puff pastry.
Full puff. We're making full puff?
Yeah, we're doing full puff.
Right, let's go in!
So, I've not done puff pastry
for a long, long time.
I'm definitely a rough puff
kind of guy.
There's a lot to do. And there's a
lot to think about and not mess up.
I don't want to overwork this.
OK, I just need to roll it out
quite thin.
"Put the butter on the dough so
it covers the bottom two thirds
"and do a single turn and chill."
A single turn and chill.
Oh, God.
Just not nailing this.
My dough is quite sticky though.
I don't know if I should be worried
about that. I don't know why.
OK, I'm going to put it
in the fridge.
I think I should probably
make my choux.
Do you remember The Shoe People?
I loved that programme.
# The Shoe, Shoe, Shoe, Shoe
Shoe People.
# Do-do-do-do-do, do. #
I've heated up the water and batter,
so I'm just going to shoot my flour
in there.
Does this look like choux pastry to
you?
I think it's meant to form
a V-shape.
So like this - a V.
Is this for the choux?
It's q-quite firm.
Yeah.
Look at that! Excalibur.
# Ahh. #
Chosen one.
Apparently it's something to do with
a triangle.
I'm not getting any triangles.
A triangle?
That's what Michael told me.
Michael?! He's not here any more.
Don't listen to him, he's gone!
It's actually really slack.
I don't know why it's so thin.
I might try it and see.
It says to make 28 circles.
I don't know if they're completely
even, but there we go.
They're not all the right size.
It's not a beautiful choux, is it?
I'm putting these in.
I'm thinking maybe 10 minutes.
I'm going to give them 10 minutes,
but if they're not puffing up
in those 10 minutes
they get pulled and I start again.
Bakers, you are halfway through
your Technical Challenge,
halfway through.
OK, kids? Halfway through.
Kids?
Don't leave me hanging. Steph?
TOGETHER: Halfway through.
Alice, how long we got left?
Halfway through.
They are listening.
Er, right. Puff pastry.
That was resting for ages,
wasn't it?
Right, so let's see where we're
going with this now.
Yeah, the next ones a book turn.
So, a book turn, we go like this
and like this...
..I think. And then in half again.
I don't really know how many times
I'm meant to turn this.
Looking for nice lamination
cos if the butter comes through
then you're going to mess up
your nice little layers
that you're trying to get.
Put you back in the freezer.
Right, shall I see the choux?
My chouxs are puffing up OK.
They're looking nice.
Nice.
I think you're a choux-in.
Those are puffing,
but not very well.
They're done.
I have some choux buns.
They're OK.
They're all very different in size,
but whatevs.
They're like little bricks.
I might just start again.
I'm starting again.
SHE SIGHS
Right, let's roll this thing.
So, "Roll the pastry
into a 28cm square."
But it's meant to be kind of
in sheets of laminated butter.
This seems like it's more in chunks.
Chunky monkey.
I'm trying to work out why they
haven't given us many folds.
Probably because if the individual
layers are too thin
then the butter will burst through.
I think we're getting some butter
seepage. Nothing to see here.
I'm just going to leave it
to chill again.
Chilling just sorts everything out.
It's happened again.
My choux pastry is liquid
and I don't know why.
I don't understand.
I just don't understand.
Oh, for goodness' sake,
this is not going to work.
It's failed.
Go to the graveyard of choux buns.
Um, my pastry's failed as well.
All the butter's burst
through my pastry.
You can see all the butter
at the top.
I've got to remake everything.
Bakers, you have one ho..
Excuse me? Hello?
Bakers, you have one hour.
Just one hour.
Um, I might just go home now.
Oh, my God.
We'll put that puff pastry in.
We are in the oven.
"Place a large baking tray
on top and bake."
Otherwise it goes, "Bwoosh!"
Darling, that's not a good face.
No, everything's gone wrong, Sandi.
I'm remaking my pastry,
I'm remaking my choux,
but the second choux
hasn't worked either. OK.
I make choux all the time.
What's the p...?
Well, slow down.
What's the problem?
My choux was too thin, I couldn't
pipe it. It was just blobs.
ROSIE SIGHS
Take a breath. You've got this, OK?
I don't think I do have this, but
you're very lovely. Yes, you do.
So, what's next?
"Make the creme chiboust."
Chibouse? Chibouss? Chiboust?
Chiboo?
Chiboo.
So, this is the creme pat,
but I need to make it into
a creme chiboust.
If only I'd concentrated more
in French lessons
and then I might know
what chiboust means.
Je ne sais pas. I don't know.
My creme pat's thickening very fast.
To the point where it's
slightly splitting.
I think if I get a whisk
I can just sort it out.
Oh!
I've made a creme patisserie before.
I've just read about the stiff
egg whites, so I'm assuming
it's more, like, mousse-like, maybe?
So, three leaves... gelatine.
Um, I have decided...
..just to stick with
my original pastry
because I've got so much to remake.
Come on, Rosie, you can do it.
If anyone can do that,
you can do it.
These egg whites look
a bit ropey, shall we say?
So I'm just folding this in.
That's lovely, isn't it? Pillowy.
I want it to be smooth but thick
cos it's going inside my choux.
That's my third attempt at the choux
and it's still pretty slack.
But whatever, we're piping this.
This is being piped.
I'm just having a quick look
at this bad boy.
I mean, it's pretty terrible as far
as how much butter's come out of it.
No idea what this is like,
but I can see it browning
quite a lot on the edge.
I think that might be done.
OOh, ya BLEEP.
Didn't really lift up at the edges,
did it? It's not a great puff.
Um, I'm making my creme pat again.
I forgot to add the gelatine because
I am a massive, massive idiot.
I've done everything either
twice or three times.
How long have we got left?
Bakers, you've got half an hour.
Cooked through? I don't know?
I-I'm going with it, I'm going
with it, I'm going with it.
The choux is in. Who knows what
it's going to do, but it's in.
It's not over. It's not over.
Next is making a caramel
and then dipping these in it.
It is starting to colour.
It should do.
I just don't want it to burn.
Lots can go wrong in caramel.
Oh, yeah!
I hope that that's not burnt.
SHE SIGHS
I worry that that's too dark.
Too late now.
I might just make the top ones
a little lighter, maybe?
OK, right, so let's try that again.
The choux buns are actually
puffing up. The chouxs are puffing.
Thank God.
15 minutes.
How do we assemble this bad boy?
"Trim the sheet of puff pastry and
cut into two rectangles."
Sawing wood.
Everything's ready to go,
apart from obviously the caramel.
Please work.
Pipe a wide ribbon of creme
chiboust down the middle.
This looked so nice when
I was making it,
now it just looks congealed.
Fill each choux bun with
creme chiboust. Ooh.
You can... Ooh.
You can feel it going in.
I don't really know if this is
going in or not.
I'm trying to see which ones
look vaguely reasonable.
I feel like...
OK, let me tell you. OK.
That guy, good.
That guy's an idiot.
ALICE: I don't know how I'm going to
fit these on.
What I'm going to have to do here is
make mine kind of come off the edge
as much as I can.
Ow-ee! They're really hot.
They look like choux buns.
Not beautiful choux buns, but they
are recognisably buns of choux.
STEPH: How long have we got?
You have five minutes left, bakers.
ALICE: Do you like my two-tone
caramel?
This looks really terrible.
Don't fall off now.
It just says decorate and, like,
I don't really know what else
I could do.
I've lost count. I don't even
know if I've done enough
or too many or anything.
Lost track of everything.
I think that's going to be
as good as it gets.
I've got a two-tone
caramel thing going on.
Just got to make sure I've got
the prettiest ones sitting on top.
I think she's got a lot less
to worry about
than she's worrying about.
I have something. It really looked
like I was going to have nothing.
SANDI: Bakers, your time is up.
DAVID: Whoo!
Please do what you're
automatically doing.
Our babies are all grown up.
They don't need us.
They don't need us any more.
Just as well.
Oh, my God. I can't believe
I nearly dropped that.
Prue and Paul are looking for
a beautiful gateau St Honore
with crisp puff pastry and perfect
choux buns filled with
silky smooth chiboust, finished with
caramel and Chantilly cream.
Shall we start with this one?
The colour of the choux buns
doesn't look too bad.
Yeah, they're all pretty much
the same size.
The pastry looks a bit soggy. Yeah.
Butter's poured out.
I'm just trying to get down
to the chiboust down here.
Well, that's split.
Good caramel.
Nice and crackly and thin.
It's a very nice pastry.
It's not perfect,
but it's OK.
Moving on to number two. You know
when you get the big holes here?
Normally an indication that you
have lost a little bit of butter,
but you can see the flake anyway
and it is thin.
Choux buns look a bit irregular
in colour, don't they? Hmm.
Some are dark, some are light. Yeah.
The chiboust is a little bit like
scrambled egg...
..but it tastes OK.
I love the size of those choux buns.
They're not too big.
And, moving on to this one, the
Chantilly cream's over-whipped.
The pastry looks good.
Feels good, it's quite solid.
I'd say that
caramel is overdone. It is overdone.
Yeah, you can taste can't you,
the burnt caramel as well.
It's too strong.
This looks quite delicate, this one.
Except that the choux buns
are all upside down.
It's got a nice flake,
it's nice and thin.
Nice crisp pastry.
Mmm, how's the chiboust?
It's pretty smooth, isn't it?
Hmm, good.
The puff's good as well.
I don't complain about this at all
except that the choux buns
are definitely upside down.
They are for sure.
OK, this'll be an interesting
judging.
Prue and Paul will now rank the
gateau St Honore from worst to best.
OK, in fourth position is this one.
Whose is this?
Alice, you had a few issues
with the puff.
There is problems with the Chantilly
and the chiboust as well
and you burnt the caramel
on the bottom.
In third place is this one.
Steph, a little untidy,
too much caramel,
so it's become a bit lumpy.
But delicious.
In second place is this one.
Whose is this?
Actually, not bad at all.
It looks like scrambled egg though,
the chiboust,
and there's a little bit of
sogginess running through
the puff pastry as well.
Which leaves this one.
Yeah!
Rosie! Well done, Rosie.
It's absolutely perfect, except
the profiteroles are upside down.
Otherwise, it's delicious.
I'm sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
I-I can't believe it.
That was my most stressful bake...
..and I won it.
Another second.
The sixth second in a Technical.
Second will get you
all the way to the Final.
Might not make you win the Final,
but it'll get you all the way there.
They're going to be picky - it's the
Semifinal - they're not going to
just let anything go.
I've just got to try and
pick it up again tomorrow.
There's not as many left now,
is there?
So your chances get less and less.
So, yesterday, everybody chugging
along, then I thought, Rosie,
going to crash and burn.
She came first in the Technical.
I mean, I don't know where we are.
Now, Steph who's won Star Baker
more than anybody else,
struggled a little bit.
Her Signature tasted delicious,
but the texture was all wrong.
What about David? I think
he struggled in his Signature.
And it came down to the look of it.
So I think the steady dark horse
in this race is Alice.
Alice is steady, usually, but she
did do a pretty poor Technical.
Knowing it's the final next week,
there is no room for error now.
So it may be the person who fails,
rather than the person who triumphs?
I think putting Patisserie Week
in a semifinal is pretty cruel.
Was that your idea?
That your idea?
Masterstroke.
EVIL LAUGHTER
Get that man a white cat.
Morning, bakers, welcome to your
semifinal Showstopper Challenge.
Today, the judges would like you
to create a spectacular
sugar glass display case,
completely transparent,
and inside, there needs to be
an edible depiction of something
that you hold precious to you
in your life.
Now, I know we all love him,
but it can't be Noel, OK?
Could be me, I could totally
fit in a glass case? Totally.
Er, your glass case can be any
shape that you like,
but the object inside must contain
at least one baked element.
You know what I'm talking about,
cakes, biscuits, that kind of thing.
You have four and a half hours.
On your marks. Get set.
Bake.
I'm trying to tell myself
I'm calm, and then if I keep
telling myself,
then, it might happen.
It is a bit surreal that this is
the bake that could get us
into the final, but I'm not really
thinking about that,
I'm thinking about
whether I can do it.
So, yeah, I'm scared.
PRUE: What we want is a real
celebration of patisserie.
Showcasing it in a sugar glass
cabinet emphasises that.
Patisserie Week is all about
precision,
so trying not to wing it.
like I normally do.
This sugar glass cabinet
has to be crystal clear.
We want to see through it,
just like through a pane of glass.
PAUL: And then, you've got to think
of what they're going to put
in the middle.
It has to be really high-class,
exquisite pastries.
Flavours, they can use
anything they wish.
Anything from a banana,
to a raspberry, to a coffee.
We want lots of different textures.
Jellies, mousses,
ganache, maybe sponge cake,
but it has to work together
so that it feels as if it's married,
and that's how it should be.
This is going to be quite
a tricky challenge.
We're looking, really, for
an artist, an architect, a baker.
This is semifinal.
It has to be just amazing.
I've got keep on top of things
today, because timing
is an issue, and I've got
a glass case to make.
NOEL: What the bakers present inside
their case is entirely up to them,
but it must have one baked element.
I'm starting with my cake dough.
Butter, flour, flour, eggs, done.
This is a joconde sponge.
Yes, that's what we're doing.
I'm making my genoise sponge.
Yeah, I'm in the zone.
SANDI: The bakers have
four and a half hours to complete
this monster challenge,
and time is something
that is very much
on Rosie's mind.
This is my brioche dough
that I'm making at the moment.
Mine is about the concept of time,
spending time with family,
but lately, I've spent a lot less
time with family
than I would have liked.
I mean, I haven't really
seen my husband, to be honest,
since I started this.
He's in my house and he sometimes
clears the kitchen up for me.
Inside Rosie's sugar glass case
will be a range
of classic patisserie, including
miniature choux bun religieuses,
brioche Tartes Tropeziennes,
and a chocolate tartlet,
all resting on an orange sable
Breton clock face.
We've given you four and a half
hours to complete this challenge.
Yeah. When does your baking stop
and your actual construction start?
I'm getting the baked elements
completed and the fillings
in their components, ready to go,
and then stop all of that
and focus on the box.
Well, you had a great day
yesterday, Rosie.
With luck, you will have
another one today.
Er...
SHE LAUGHS
This is definitely going
to be a sweet cake.
It's going to have quite
a substantial amount
of grated beetroot in one,
and grated parsnip in another.
These root vegetables have a lot
of natural sugars in them.
We're going for six layers.
They're not thick layers, though,
you've got to remember that.
Got to remember, not thick,
not thick layers.
I am just putting my brioche dough
into the little moulds.
That's the genoise sponge.
I'm doing a representation
of a coral reef.
The glass case kind of symbolises
how fragile the oceans are,
so I'm going to try
and represent that in a cake.
Yeah. We'll see how it goes.
You never know.
NOEL: Inside Alice's sugar glass
case will be a mirror glazed
entremets cake, built up of five
separately set
and then layered elements.
It will be adorned with vibrant
isomalt corals and chocolate shells.
Wow, there's a lot going
on with this. Yes.
It does sound amazing, the flavours
that you've got going on as well.
I mean there's so many layers
to this. Yeah. It's about getting
the timing right for every single
layer to build it up. Yeah. Good.
Fantastic, good luck, Alice.
We'll leave you to it.
Thank you very much.
You look a bit hassled.
SHE LAUGHS
Thank you.
DAVID: Right, I'm going to put
this cake in now.
It's going in at 180 degrees,
50 minutes and then check.
Let's do it, all in together.
I'm blind baking my little
tartlet cases
and cooking my brioche
at the same time.
That's the genoise sponge.
About 15 minutes probably.
Right, so, that's one element done.
Next, ganache.
Right, I'm going to make
the maple syrup buttercream.
It goes really well with these,
kind of, spicy cakes,
it's very creamy.
I'm going to make choux pastry.
Yeah, after yesterday,
I am absolutely terrified.
I'm making my entremets mousse.
I didn't think it was that
ambitious, and now I'm starting
to think, maybe it was.
But it's the semifinal,
so I wasn't going to try
and play it safe.
SANDI: But not all the bakers
are employing
the same strategy as Alice.
I definitely haven't planned this,
so it's kind of, like,
right to the wire.
It's important to not have
given yourself so much to do
that you don't have time
to make things look good.
I think that would be a disaster.
David's ambitions do stretch
to a sugar glass terrarium,
home to a tower of sponges,
made with beetroot and prunes,
parsnips and apricots
and topped off with elegantly-piped
buttercream cacti and succulents.
So, you've got a cake, essentially?
Yes.
I don't want a door wedge of sponge
with a load of buttercream in it.
I'm trying to do it neatly... Yeah.
..and make it patisserie-like.
This is my craquelin.
It's just flour, sugar and butter.
You put a little disc
on the top of each choux bun.
It makes them slightly
more crunchy on top,
and my choux looks OK... maybe.
Once they've puffed up in the oven,
we'll decide.
With the entremets, all the layers
have to be set,
so I'm setting the lemon
and the raspberry first.
This is going to be for my ganache.
You don't want it to boil.
I get scared when I'm doing
this one.
I am making an opera cake,
an ode to my amazing grandpa.
He's called Derek.
Derek Percival George.
That's a good name.
Strong name, eh?
SANDI: Sitting inside her seamless
glass sugar case,
Steph's opera cake will alternate
layers of joconde sponge
with chocolate ganache
and orange creme au beurre.
Have you practised this at home?
Yeah, few times.
You've done OK in the time?
Yeah, I just... I'm always worried
that something's going to go wrong,
but that's just me.
You'll be fine, Steph. Thank you.
I'm allergic to opera, sorry.
Oh, God.
Let's have a look at this cake.
These are the Tartes Tropeziennes.
Do not quote my pronunciation.
If we're shoddy on a few,
then it's just going to have to be
what it is, because
it's as good as it gets.
Sugar glass cabinet challenge,
I think this plays to the strengths
of most of them.
That's the genoise sponge.
Alice is the one that's
surprised me.
She's really going for it now.
She's got curd, she's got bavarois,
she's got genoise sponge.
This one's fine,
the raspberry one is set,
it's just more moussey
than I would've liked.
Next, we're doing the creme
au beurre.
It's basically a buttercream,
super rich.
PRUE: Steph's doing
a straightforward opera cake,
really, with a few macarons.
This is for my macarons.
No, I've not made macarons
in the competition.
I've barely made them in life.
I have put the choux in the oven.
Rosie's got quite a lot to do,
cos she's making the religieuses
and the Tropeziennes.
All my stuff is patisserie, because
I thought, it's Patisserie Week,
so I'm trying to do a celebration
of patisserie,
so, yeah, much patisserie.
This is a fancy piece of equipment.
Cuts your cake perfect.
David's doing a lot of sponges.
Is that delicate enough?
Yeah, David's might just give us
a great big cake.
I think I'm a little bit
ahead of time. How long's it been?
Yeah, don't spin that too fast,
cos I'll take off.
Is this it? I asked for
an air conditioning unit.
I'm going to complain.
Bakers, you've got three hours left.
There's a bit of a breeze.
Right, just don't panic.
Right.
Everything needs to be
in the freezer in five minutes.
I need to pour my bavarois in.
I'm going in with these macarons.
My choux looks OK.
I'm going to set this
for as long as possible.
How are you?
SANDI LAUGHS
Choux was not your friend yesterday.
Ah, see look. Already perfection.
Functional choux. Functional choux.
Like a, sort of, lace-up brogue.
Right, now I need to get on
with some biscuits.
The glass box is going to be
supported by a biscuit edge,
so I'm making six biscuit frames.
These are my windows. Sort of
an old-style Parisian window.
It's just spiced biscuit dough.
Yeah, I want to get these baked.
I'm just going to
go in the oven with this.
About 15 minutes.
All right,
I need to pull myself together.
Can you tell that
I'm starting to panic?
It's gonna be really tight.
NOEL: Bakers,
you are halfway through.
This is in preparation
for some isomalt.
SANDI: Isomalt is a sugar substitute
that doesn't caramelise
and will remain clear.
Isomalt is just a sugar.
It is just sugar.
"Inverted sugar"
is what isomalt is.
This stuff gets so hot.
I think it's about 300 degrees
or something when it's melted.
Are these gloves from work?
Yeah. Are they?
NOEL LAUGHS
Do you wear two?
For this, cos it's hot.
Or for anything really stinky.
Stinky?
HE LAUGHS
What would be stinky?
I'm not talking about smelly things.
Come on. No.
Whisper. What's the smelliest thing
you've come across?
There are many things that smell.
Anything's that gone a bit horrible.
Nasty abscesses can smell bad,
lots of things can smell bad.
Mm. Mm.
This is more interesting
than the show.
We should do a spin-off.
Got all my panes.
So they're ready to fill
with isomalt.
Yeah, that's fine.
The strength of the biscuit is such
an integral part to the bake.
It's gingerbread, very delicate.
The glass is going to go in there.
That is the aim.
SANDI: Although most bakers
are using biscuit to reinforce
their sugar glass, Steph is making
panes she'll risk glueing together.
How hot is that right now?
Really hot. Finger?
Don't put your finger in there.
Finger? No, no, no, no.
Burn it? OK.
It's kind of the exact shade
I wanted.
My glass is going to be kind of
wavy, like the ocean.
Fingers crossed I don't drop it
somewhere, or it doesn't break.
Ideally, you want this to be
glass clear.
So the blowtorch,
it gets rid of surface bubbles.
I've had mixed results this week.
If it's murky, I'm just going
to say, "Well, just a reflection
"of our oceans, isn't it?"
I don't know how transparent
mine's going to be.
I'll just do what I can.
Yeah, I mean, I was supposed
to be blowtorching
the bubbles off the back,
but I don't have time for that now.
And that is frankly the least
of my worries.
It's basically already set.
Doesn't take long.
Not doing very well with being
delicate with this.
Can you tell it's not really my bag?
Yeah, they're OK.
It's not that clear though.
Can you see my face?
Well, that's quite clear, isn't it?
You all right? Yeah, all this
baking's making me feel
a bit peckish.
Ah, that's why I got you these,
Delicious Crisps. Delicious Crisps?
I've never heard of those.
Oh, they're really good.
This is not one of your tricks
again? Don't be ridiculous.
Go for it. Sure?
Cos we're a double act.
I know and I love you.
And it's all about trust.
Yes, go for it.
SHE CHUCKLES
Bakers, you have one hour.
I've gotta have eye surgery now,
I hope you're happy with yourself.
SANDI LAUGHS
I'm quite behind,
but I don't really know...
SHE LAUGHS
Erm...
I'm going to try one of these
macarons.
I think they're meant to be
more chewy than that.
Right, just don't panic.
This is my mirror glaze.
I'm just getting my cake
out of the freezer.
There's less than an hour now,
so I'm feeling very stressy.
It's been in the freezer
for quite a while.
I'm starting to panic,
cos I've got an hour left.
I just need this to work.
Can you make it work?
You're not normally this stressed.
What do you mean I'm not normally
this stressed?
I'm always this stressed.
I don't normally have to calm you
down. I have to calm down Rosie
or I have to calm down Steph.
I have to get David a bit more
agitated, that's really my main job.
Woo!
Assembly time for the cake.
I've got a beetroot prune cake
on the bottom,
and then I'm going to have
a layer of parsnip,
maple syrup with cream cheese icing
to go in between those.
These are my little
Tartes Tropeziennes.
They are bit dry, but they're
getting a massive bit of cream
in there, so cream
fixes everything, right?
STEPH: Think we're done.
Right, I need to make isomalt coral.
This is my buttercream
for the succulents. Happy?
Yeah, it's just, everything's a bit
busy today, isn't it?
I don't know. I've been lying down.
THEY LAUGH
Is it a busy one?
Oh, yeah, definitely.
Look how quick you are
with that business.
Yeah, but we've gotta be quick.
If you were doing this on your own.
I wouldn't do this on my own.
No, why, would you?
It'd be too weird.
Breathe, breathe, breathe,
breathe, breathe, breathe, breathe.
I'm really, really behind.
Once I've done this,
it's time to start thinking about
the glass display box.
That's the next bit of fun.
Bakers, you have half an hour,
just half an hour.
You can do a lot in half an hour.
I'm in panic mode now.
The construction bit will be
the difficult bit.
This is the stage where you've got
to start being very, very delicate.
If you break it, gone.
It's a challenge, so we all like
challenges, don't we?
But it's likely to be my downfall,
shall we say.
OK.
Yeah, I'm assembling.
I just need to have a glass case.
How will I do this bit, guys?
I'm glueing it with the isomalt.
Probably isn't the best way
to do this,
but needs must.
I am not confident about it
in the slightest.
It's quite Art Deco, this design.
I'm going for rustic.
You know, if I'm really honest,
it is me.
I'm not perfect.
How long have we got?
Bakers, you have...
..15 minutes left, 15 minutes.
He's lying, isn't he?
Oh, got to make chocolate soil.
This is creme pat.
This is going in my little tarte.
I'm really, really, really stressed.
I'm just making a chocolate
starfish.
Literally just moulding it with
some coloured white chocolate.
We'll just freestyle a little bit
with the decoration.
All the elements are there.
It's wonky.
Right, which is the front?
The box goes over the cake.
Bakers, you have one minute,
just one minute.
OK, I don't know what to do.
Just going to hold this in place
and hope the caramel sets.
Probably a bit clumsy,
but nearly there.
I don't know if I can glue that.
Right, bakers, your time is up.
HE EXHALES
SHE SIGHS
It's a bit of a mess,
but it is done.
It's judgment time for the bakers'
show stopping sugar cabinets.
Steph, please bring up
your sugar glass case.
It's pretty clear.
It's quite like old antique glass.
I think you've done
a good job there.
Let's have a look, shall we?
It's very neat.
Very dark chocolate.
That looks very pretty.
You're a very good baker, Stephanie.
Oh.
You really are.
The sponge is a little more dense
than I'd have liked
but on the other hand,
you've got so many layers.
If it had been very light,
it would've been difficult.
It's very patisserie in its style
by the use of the macarons.
Everything you've done is very neat,
very tidy,
very Steph and the box is good too.
Yeah, I think you've done
a good job, thank you.
It's very neat.
And I love the coloured glass.
It's quite clear.
You can see through it.
It's a bit mottled in places.
That's very neat too.
It is very neat.
I, I, uh, it has to be absolutely
level and it's not because it...
it bends down.
It's wonderfully light.
Like a very good carrot cake.
Quite spicy,
as always with you.
Blindfolded, I'd
know that was yours.
Patisserie week is
all about delicacy, finesse,
intricate detail and I think
by putting sponge on sponge
on sponge on sponge on sponge,
I think it's slightly wayward.
You need something more delicate,
more finesse.
I absolutely agree,
it would've been better
if there'd been a bit more
showing off of patisserie work.
I like the look of it.
Does look like old glass.
It's a good concept.
It's a bit simplistic
considering it's a showpiece,
it's a centrepiece,
it's a show stopper. Yeah.
What's difficult is,
it's the same colour... Hmm.
..all the way around.
What you've done is really
interesting because you've taken
a concept like time and family,
but it's the concept that
pulls them all together,
not the gastronomic dish.
These are a bit boring, a bit dry.
Dry and...
Yeah, there's no flavour to it.
Dry and floury.
The little tarte in the middle's
delicious. Thanks.
The religieuse are a little
bit off the mark as well.
Because they're so small... OK.
..you need to pack more of a punch
but making that a centrepiece,
hmm, it's a tricky one that one.
It's just the mix
that doesn't quite work.
You can't really see much of it,
to be honest.
If it'd had been clear,
it would be astonishing.
That is really lovely
and I like the boldness that
you've done a really big one.
Hmm, lovely flavour.
Very nice, the whole fresh
raspberries in there.
There is flavour in there.
It's not particularly strong.
The strong part of it
is the raspberry.
The raspberry comes through
beautifully.
The weakness is the mousse
down at the bottom. OK.
It's not very mousse-like.
I think your display is very good
and it really shows off
what your theme was.
If you'd have asked me about an hour
ago, I think I would've said
I was going home but
I hope I've turned it around.
Yeah, it wasn't great.
I'm just a bit gutted to be honest,
just a bit gutted. Yeah.
This is patisserie week
and I didn't really do a patisserie.
They said it was more cake
and that's what I was dreading.
Am I going to be penalised because
that's not very patisserie?
It was pretty tight,
coming into the Showstopper.
How do we feel they did?
It's moved round a bit.
Alice has done a great job.
That's a decent looking entremets.
I think Steph did a great job.
She really bounced back,
actually, in the Showstopper.
She showed us a lot of
patisserie skills.
The ones who you were
not impressed by...
..the one that looks like a...
..well, looks like a sort
of sandwich, doesn't it?
It's basically a stack
of sponge cakes,
and although that's
technically patisserie,
it's not what we were asking for.
His cabinet, though,
was very, very good.
So if we have to tick
the elegant column,
that's not going to happen
with Rosie's? No... I have...
I have serious issues with this.
Because the little cakes
that she made are so dry,
no flavour in them whatsoever.
I don't think picking Star Baker's
going to be that difficult.
I think the hard one is, who's going
to leave us at this late stage?
It's the worst time to go out,
right?
It is, because you're just,
you're nearly there.
I trust you two, and we're going
to go away for five hours
while you talk about it. Yes,
I think so. We could be a while.
Hello, bakers.
Well done for all your hard work.
I've got the great job this week
of announcing the Star Baker
and the person that will be going
straight through to the final.
So, the Star Baker this week is...
..Alice.
Well done.
You're in the final.
Congratulations.
So that means I have the horrible
job, it gets so difficult.
One of you will not be going
through to the final.
Can I just say, very well done to
everybody before I announce it.
But I'm afraid the person who will
not be joining us next week is...
..Rosie. I'm so sorry.
You did so well.
You did an amazing job. Amazing.
You pulled it back together.
Yesterday you were incredible.
Well done, sweetheart. I'm so sorry.
ROSIE: I'm gutted. I am gutted.
I just have to be happy with
everything that I've done so far.
Oh, Rosie. You did so well.
Paul came up to me and said that it
was just that one part of that last
bake.
Rosie tried to show a lot of skills,
but they weren't a good
collection together
and she didn't do them
particularly well.
PAUL: Rosie slipped up.
Sorry, Rosie.
Which is the saddest part about it.
But you are a bloody good baker.
Thanks.
Likewise, David, who was
also in line for possibly going.
He basically made a cake.
PRUE: There's no doubt about it.
If Rosie had had a good day,
it would be David who was going.
I feel like I could've
just dodged a bullet, yeah.
Paul wasn't impressed,
and it just wasn't patisserie.
On the other hand,
Alice winning Star Baker...
Thank you!
..Alice is one to watch.
She's got stronger and stronger.
I'm probably going to have a
mini-meltdown this week from the
pressure!
What a great way to
go into the final. I know.
Isn't that wonderful?
We've got three very
talented bakers in there.
Oh, my God!
Well done, Steph. Thank you.
Three bakes to go!
And they're very artistic bakers.
They're very imaginative.
If they all bring their A-game,
next week's final
will be one of the best
finals we've ever had.
That feels good!
I'm in the final.
Next time...
I am delighted to tell you,
after ten weeks
of intense competition...
Ah!
Pff.
Whew.
..the winner...
Oh, my God I'm shaking.
Trying to stay calm, but my heart
is like, "dum-dum-dum-dum-dum."
..of the 2019 Great
British Bake Off is...
Are you a Star Baker in the making?
If you'd like to apply for
the next series of Bake Off,
go to channel4.com/takepart.
Subtitles by Red Bee Media